ladies and gentlemen please welcome
my friend mary mccarthy
hi everyone
um
you and i actually went through your
mom's exhibition at a gallery yeah and i
picked out one of her photographs
of the cherries yes and you were in
somewhere in the caribbean yeah and we
were eating maraschino cherries we'd put
them all out on the wall but mum just
saw the light was hitting it and the
right way and it's like such a beautiful
print it's like a fabulous art print now
so so i wake up and go to sleep to that
it's right next to my bed and i just
feel your family's beautiful energy and
now everybody's talking about the
documentary that just came out this
eight hour odyssey
what is your perspective
on all of it you know what i'm just so
first of all i'm so proud but i went to
the london premiere with dad it really
meant a lot to him because
all of the rumors were that they were
fighting around that time and actually
it shows their collaboration them
creating and it shows you know that they
were friends and having a laugh and my
mom's in it a lot so i get to see her
and two months ago
and it was for the kind food my food
inspiration
and your mom is your food insurance
and you guys have meatless mondays in
the uk
we do meet free monday and i grew up
with mama the
kitchen was the heart of the home i read
a story about your parents like came to
you when they decided to be vegetarians
right yeah and what did they say
mum just said look i don't want to cook
meat at home anymore it's your choice
but then the great thing as a family
because we were all vegetarian i grew up
talking about food like you have that
gap on your plate so i grew up
discussing the gap on the plates we'd
come up with ideas so you never feel
like you're missing out on anything so
that's how the show came about i like to
cook hearty
nice that really satisfying like you say
healthy but i love fried food and i like
me too
you could fry you and all that i try
i
try to make it as healthy but satisfying
but i just want to do my mom proud
spread the word and not be judgmental if
you want ideas for things that's what
i'm here for but you know i'm not gonna
preach to you okay so i'm really excited
to try these cookies teach me how to
make them because they have an orange
component and i love oranges yes my
favorite
combination is chocolate orange okay
these are very chocolatey orange cookies
and it's super easy let's go so we have
two types of sugar half a cup of brown
sugar half which i think would light
brown sugar demerara sugar um we call
this demerara sugar i think at home we
have slightly different things the
darker one is coconut um sugar which
adds a really nice caramelly flavor
should i whisk it together use white
sugar if you don't have any of these
sugars it's really not with that
get now this is coconut oil this is an
odorless one so it doesn't taste too
coconutty for a little bit of extra
flavor one tablespoon of vanilla
and then we're gonna
a cup and a half of all-purpose flour
and one teaspoon of baking powder just
to give it a little lift
and now we're going to chuck in the
juice of one orange and the zest and the
zest of one orange yes
very orangey where did you learn this
recipe mary i kind of
made it up i was thinking what are my
favorite combinations
right i'm just gonna use i like
chocolate and coffee too get your hands
in there to bring it together at the end
okay so tell me about these scoops i
hear you love them it has changed my
life whether it's a cookie
or some type of meatball or whatever it
is a vegetable or a veggie ball i know i
felt gross saying meat around you but
then you said no judgment so show me you
just chuck it in here i never i've never
used one of these what it does
is the
evenness is so important for the cook as
far as it all cooking
the same and that sort of balance
usually when i do cookies for people
they're like especially with the kids
you're like which one do you want and
they all look to see which has the most
chocolate in it
so my plan was to get two pieces of
chocolate
equal amounts and just push it into
that small each cookie
and then you kind of flatten the cookie
down at the same time that's really
smart and then we have no arguments over
who gets the most chocolate because it's
all fair and even nice and easy right
okay so
the oven at what temp in time man 350
for 10 minutes
yummy okay cheers babe oh hang on i have
to tell you i'm doing a new book feeding
creativity where
because i hate doing food photography i
was like i'll cook something and take it
to a creative person i like and take
pictures of them so you're going in the
book mary takes the most beautiful
pictures she's been in galleries and
music all over the world
one more one more
last one
that's the one thank you so much i'm so
glad that you would come on the show
please come back let's do so many things
yes i'll bring i'll bring a truckload of
food next time let's do it thanks be
sure to check out mary
mccartney plus
[Music]
you